In this lecture, we will
discuss how visualization
can offer insights in
the area of policing
in urban environments.
The explosion of
computerized data
affects all parts of
society, including policing.
In the past, human
judgment and experience
was the only tool in identifying
patterns in criminal behavior.
Police forces around the
United States and the world
are augmenting human
judgment with analytics.
Los Angeles police
worked for months
to catch Manson
and his followers.
These days the LAPD is on an
offensive to prevent crime.
Its latest weapon is
a computer program
that can actually predict
where crimes will happen.
And justice
correspondent Bob Orr
has a first look at the results.
In the Foothill Division
north of downtown Los Angeles,
police are patrolling
the largely
working-class neighborhoods
with specially marked maps.
The small red squares
are hot spots,
where computers project
property crimes are most likely.
It's called predictive policing.
A program which Captain
Sean Malinowski says
puts officers on the
scene before crimes occur.
65% of our crimes are
burglary, grand theft auto,
and burglary for motor vehicle.
And that's what these
boxes represent.
That's a pretty small
box, 500 feet by 500 feet.
Yes, it is a small area.
These crime
prediction boxes come
from the same kind of
mathematical calculation used
to predict earthquakes
and aftershocks.
By analyzing the times, dates,
and places of recent crimes
computers project hot spots for
burglaries, break-ins, and car
thefts.
LA's Police Chief
Charlie Beck says
increasing police patrols
inside those boxes
denies criminals opportunity.
The real measure of this is
not how many people you catch,
it's how much crime you prevent.
I love catching people.
It's what I live for.
But, what I'd rather do is live
in a place and work in a place
where crime didn't happen.
Chief Beck, a 35-year veteran
and the father of two LAPD
officers, has faced
some skepticism
in selling the
predictive concept.
You're a street cop.
I am.
So somebody comes to you with
a computer program that says,
here we're going to
predict the future,
we're going to tell you where
crime is going to occur.
Aren't some of the guys
on the street just going
to roll their eyes
and say, oh come on?
Well, of course.
I mean, that's the
nature of human beings.
I mean everybody thinks that
they do their profession as
well as it can be done already,
so they don't need any help.
If this old street
cop can change the way
that he thinks about
this stuff, then I
know that my kids
can do the same.
The LAPD began testing the
predictive policing model here
in the Foothill
Division in November,
and the early results
are encouraging.
Burglaries are down 33%, and
violent crime is also down 21%.
That success will allow
Beck to expand the program
to other parts of the city and
leverage limited resources.
I'm not going to get more money.
I'm not going to get more cops.
But I have to be better
at using what I have,
and that's what predictive
policing is about.
It's also about driving
the crime rate lower.
Crime here has dropped
nine straight years.
With these small red
boxes, LA is aiming for 10.
Bob Orr, CBS News, Los Angeles.
The Los Angeles Police
Chief Charlie Beck
writes, "I'm not going
to get more money.
I'm not going to get more cops.
I have to be better
at using what I have,
and that's what predictive
policing is about.
If this old street
cop can change the way
that he thinks about
this stuff, then I
know that my officers
can do the same."
Let me comment on the
role of analytics.
The analytical tools you
have learned in this class
can be used to make these
predictive policing models
possible.
However, communicating the
results of these models
is critical.
A linear regression
output table will not
be of use to a police
person on patrol.
Visualization bridges the
gap between the analytics
and the end user.